what's going on guys this is post Malone
and we're going undercover on the
internet and this is actually me Twitter
so post Malone pays a homie $1,000 a day
to handle his beer bongs post where do I
apply this is not true
Alec used to be the beer bong handler he
did not make $1000 a day I don't have
that kind of cash what do you guys think
post Malone is thinking about right now
hashtag stoner nation I don't even
really smoke anymore I guess I'm really
thinking about call of duty because all
I do is really play call of duty
nowadays posted that one oh [ __ ] I've
been heavy with that hashtag rockstar
beat who produced it any uh no it was
produced by a guy named tank god he's a
young kid I met him through Diddy son
and we just kind of had a blast and it
just kind of happened naturally and it
was a lot of fun blast that seriously
how did post Malone not win sexiest man
alive that's a great question and I feel
like I was snuffed on that Facebook what
does post Malone smell like woah don't
suck me dude I smell good I smell like a
normal person a lot of ladies say that
they love my Musk I won't wear any
deodorant or anything but I have a Musk
and it's just kind of like naturally
enticing to females but I don't smell
bad that's a common misconception and I
did a poll with people around town and
the consensus is that I don't smell
answers.com seriously it's actually me
what rhymes with Malone Malone runs
better with baritone or saxophone than
with phone or tone so I'm kind of like
adding on to what you guys have yeah but
if you can rhyme words without being
exact so you can say Malone home that's
what I do I really suck at rhyming so I
just kind of make words fit I bend the
English language to my will answered
Laura
I'm waiting from the suburbs and I
aspire to be a rapper I have no clue
what to rap about though what should I
do rap about what makes you happy
rap about your kill death ratio rap
about your dog your car how your parents
don't understand you you can see that
what I did when I was a little kid I
would rap about stuff that I wanted like
hey I'm working my ass off and I want
this stuff in the future because you're
not being braggadocious you just but
you're still cool because you know what
all this stuff is how do people come up
with a rap name rap name generators or
just if you have a smart brain you can
use that to think of names at work think
of something you think is cool and then
make it cool to other people what
myers-briggs type this post Malone well
I'll get back to you because I haven't
taken the test yet but I'd say [ __ ]
dope if that's an outcome do you think
it's still possible to be a successful
white rapper these days oh yeah I do
um you know I had to fight some [ __ ]
talking and fight some you know hey at
the beginning and there's still people
that don't like me but I mean I'm just
trying to do what I do and make the best
music that I can and make music that I
love and and just kick ass as much as I
can
YouTube anyone know where this was
filmed it's somewhere outside of LA in
the desert somewhere I don't even know
I'm pretty sure you can replicate this
just drive an hour outside and you could
replicate it anywhere more twitter you
may not believe it but it's actually me
I hope everyone has a good day except
the person that broke postpones heart
and I fall apart
who are you you know I wrote the song
about a when I was a little naive high
school boy so this is about a high
school study that we won't disclose but
she's a real Mick [ __ ] that I want to
be post Malone best friend how does that
happen
my beer bong holder is usually my best
friend so we're having auditions at the
forum next week be there
hurry Square and bring your funniest
jokes next why is possible and literally
my dad Wow
it's a very handsome dad great dad we do
look similar posted reddit how did he
manage to make a song with Justin Bieber
on his first album submitted by p.m.
meet all your tits it's a great easy man
straight to the point and just skip all
the [ __ ] and get right to it um at
the studio I was working on my first
album and I'm an influential friend and
we just kind of clicked and we made a
great song and he's a great guy and you
know the rest was history
my sister made this pumpkin I thought
this belongs here
and it's a pumpkin of me and a cigarette
and it looks great
happy Halloween y'all happy Halloween
Wikipedia he created his stage name
which would later be rumored to be a
reference to the professional basketball
player Karl Malone big fan about Malone
later explained on an interview with The
Breakfast Club that post is his last
name and he just made Malone up it's not
accurate and I used to say that yeah
because I feel like it would just be
it's just an easier story when I was a
little kid I was looking for a nice name
like Wiz Khalifa I just thought it kind
of rolled off the tongue so I went to a
rap name generator' and typed in Austin
Post and it came up with post Malone
postman was born in Syracuse New York
when he was in high niala
that I said I was born when I was 9
years old posso Lenne was born in
Syracuse New York period when he was 9
years old
he and his family moved to Grapevine
Texas he enjoyed playing basketball and
watching sports I have a cat named a
pili roller and I love her to death it's
kind of random this is all about sports
and where I'm from but I just want to
talk about my cat can I [ __ ] talk
about my cat submit Yahoo Answers
I want to ask this girl to homecoming
with post Malone tickets I need some
ideas party preferably I saw a couple of
these homecoming things like I will fall
apart if you don't go flex at me at prom
I'll give you a starting place all you
have to do is just go through my album
and just like I guess just put song
names and sentences and just put
quotation marks around it and it'll
she'll say yes buddy more Quorra
what does post Malone mean when he says
he was feeling Whitney this is a great
question I don't feel like I get this
question a lot his song is about like
whenever I was a little boy and I had
just moved out to LA and I was like 18
and getting into trouble and everything
and you know Whitney Houston and Houston
is associated with was like lean and so
I was saying my homie simply Houston is
in the lean yes so that's what kind of
this song was about just locking myself
in a dark place and doing bad things
what's the best lyric line on the stony
album deluxe by post Malone I think
they're all pretty shitty but that's a
really hard question I feel like I have
trouble even during my shows remember
remembering the words to the songs I
really think feeling Whitney has some of
the best song I put like you know my
whole emotion in my whole brain into
that song so just check out the whole
song you can do that on genius to some
more reddit my friend is post Malone for
Halloween I think she nailed it I saw a
lot of these and these are incredible
everybody killed it and looked great I
wanted to take a big picture with all of
the people that dressed up like me but I
didn't get to do that so I just looked
at them on the Internet does anyone know
what cigarettes post Malone smokes I
used to smoke Marlboro Reds and that was
a lot cooler of me but now I smoke girly
cigarettes like camel crush and that's
my favorite singer I like them because
you can smoke them all day and it's just
like it doesn't hurt your throat that
much bonobo red sock not really
to be hurt even more Twitter when you
find out post Malone enrolled and
attended Syracuse University for a
couple of months whereas his dining hall
where is his dorm I didn't go to
Syracuse my dad went to Syracuse is an
alumni there I went to TCC Tarrant
County Community College and yeah I
dropped out of there I wasn't very good
at school I moved to LA like a real cool
punk kid hey postman can you make a
Christmas album yes submit it
yo t-pain and post Malone y'all best
friends cuz you should be I've never met
t-pain great singer great guy I would
love to get to work with him in the near
future and enter how the [ __ ] is post
one's voice like that how does he do it
I need answers a lot of auto-tune and I
have this little it's like a little
Stevie Nicks kind of goatish thing that
I do with my with my throat some people
like it some people don't but you know I
think it makes it kind of super unique
thanks for watching this is post Malone
and this is actually me this is dope
this is changing history good [ __ ]